Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update sorry guardians if you were
hoping for a March release for Destiny's
next expansion house of wolves you're
going to be disappointed bungie's weekly
update has revealed that house of wolves
is slated for a cue to release so
sometime between April and June a
previously leaked image of a destiny
release plan showed a marked launch for
the expansion but Bungie never announced
anything bungie's post also gives a
status update on the weapons in the game
the pretty much terrible pulse rifles
are going to be getting a long-needed
buck a boost of nine point seven percent
to their base damage the ever-popular
auto rifle is getting a small 2.5%
damage nerf and a reduction in effective
range and my beloved hand cannon the
king of all guns is getting reduced
range and long-distance accuracy
presumably in an attempt to
differentiate it from the scout rifle
they've also doubled the amount of
damage shotguns do against non crucible
combatants presumably in an attempt to
get people to ever use them outside of
the crucible other changes include
reduced starting ammo the idea being
that in a crucible you'll have to pick
the right time to use your fusion rifles
and shotguns and snipers rather than
relying solely on them personally I've
given up on destiny because I'm a
quitter and I should feel bad about
myself and I do fit wait did you write
this Josh yeah I'm not coming back to
play destiny for more gaming news
gamespot com / news
you